hey guys what's up welcome to ij likes
the show where i like things and i show
the things that i've liked in the past
week to you
our first video today is gonna be meghan
tonjes talking about how instagram took
a photo of her butt off of instagram her
butt has been pretty much all over the
news around the world and it's kind of
insane after this make sure you guys go
watch her video she has so many great
points to make about body positivity and
body image and i love this girl not only
has her butt been all over the place
she's an amazing musician an amazing
person so funny so kind so caring megan
i freaking love you congratulations on
your butt being everywhere and even more
so congrats on the hashtag
bootyrevolution i even got to get on
that revolution this next video kind of
brought tears to my soul to my heart to
my eyes it's kids reacting to old
computers maybe you press shift okay
that didn't do anything where's the
mouse where's the mouse it's one of
those things you know when your
grandparents talk about having to walk
in the snow to get to school and stuff
like that that's kind of what i felt
like watching this video it's like kids
you guys don't even remember what it was
like to be using a disc to boot up your
computer you guys just don't know how
great you have it you would need
at least
850 of those computers to equal the
single power of this one small phone
what how can they do that so for you
game of thrones fans i don't know
whether you love or hate this video but
it's seth rogen and snoop dogg kind of
talking about the game of thrones giving
you a little recap the queen wouldn't
got because he killed uh they think he
came out for a year yeah they think he
killed joffrey but he didn't kill
joffrey uh peter
killed josh if hbo made this the
pre-show to game of thrones i would
probably i would definitely i would
watch it
two minutes
he's back at it again it's also been a
big week for games watchdogs came out
although i spent most of my day today or
yesterday depending upon when you're
watching this trying to freaking log on
to the servers it's still crazy to me
that these big game launches still have
so many server issues like you're pretty
much prepared for the worst or at least
you should be if you guys have played it
feel free to leave your comments below
this past weekend i had a mario kart 8
party in preparation for mario kart 8
that's coming out this weekend and i was
lucky enough to be able to get an
advanced copy of it and i've been
playing it pretty much non-stop
oh what
okay that's pretty cool so all of my
free time i've been playing it and it's
such a fun game it has lots of old map
throwback so most of the maps you've
probably seen before even that dreaded
rainbow road it drives me nuts they
drive me nuts as much as i try just not
run off the freaking road i still do i
also got a new camera it's the canon
n100 which i'm not going to talk about
here because i want to make a full
review of it it's so cool but i don't
want to talk about it yet not sponsored
i'm just in love with it so stay tuned
for that next up we have the ij book
club and as you guys know i'm such a
huge audible fan so if you guys want to
get your free book in your 30 day free
trial go to audible.com
ijustine to get that and let me know
what book you guys end up getting and as
a suggestion to you all because very
shortly the new the fault in our stars
movie will be coming out and i actually
got a chance to see it it was so good i
honestly cried for two hours straight in
the theater and like now i'm gonna
actually start to cry thinking about it
the movie was amazing it followed the
book perfectly and i even got a chance
to sit down and do a little interview
with john green so i'll be posting that
video very soon be sure to let me know
what audible book you guys get use the
code and another thing that i actually
haven't told you guys yet unless you saw
it on twitter i haven't even made the
official book announcement video yet but
i will i'm writing a book
i've been talking about doing this for a
long time i remember i remember back
when i first stopped live streaming my
life i for some of you guys who may be
new here i live streamed my life for six
months straight i wore a camera on my
head attached to said hat and after i
got done doing i was like i have to
write a book but i didn't even before
starting live casting just so many
random things have happened in my life
to all kind of lead up to this point and
the longer that i waited more things
kept happening so i'll have so many more
stories for you guys and when i do
actually make the official announcement
video that's when i'll be asking you
guys questions on what you want to see
in the book what kind of stories you
want me to tell and a lot of you have
been around since the very beginning so
in that time is when you guys will be
able to give me all of your feedback and
suggestions on what you want me to write
about sure to check out all of the links
in the description an episode of
hardwired also launched check that out
give it a like give it a favorite do
whatever it is that you guys do here on
youtube i love you i'll see you soon bye
you